so hey everybody had a little Mike
trouble on this one sound quality is not
going to be up to usual standard sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
so today I'm going to give my own
personal opinion on the age-old debate
do you watch the movie first do you read
the book first now I'm not going to be
addressing the question of which is
better the book of the move because that
is to my mind a complete case-by-case
basis you can't unless you are a
complete movie or book snob you can't
make a sweeping statement on that
sometimes the books better sometimes the
movies better sometimes they're equally
good but in different ways I do however
feel that at least for myself I can give
a very definitive answer to the question
of which you should experience first the
movie or the book and for me it's a very
simple answer it's it's the movie
it's the adaptation always every time if
there is something that I wish to
experience that is a movie or a TV show
and I know it's based off that book and
let me be clear I am right now
for the sake of simplicity I am talking
book not comic book franchise because we
start to we bring superheroes in this
conversation and we deal with the fact
that most of the movies aren't actually
straight adapting specific stories into
the most severely change forget let's
let's simplify this and you know I'm
always gonna choose the movie before the
book now I will admit that part of that
is because I am lazy in the movie or TV
show I'll just say movie cuz
and the movie is easier for me to take
it as a piece of entertainment than the
book
I'm not going to discount that as a
factor I have enough self-awareness
where I realize that but even setting
that aside if I look at all the
instances where I have both seen the
movie and read the book every time I
read the book first I didn't
particularly enjoy the movie and nearly
every time that I that I've seen the
movie first and then read the book I
enjoyed both so why is that for me it's
a matter of extracted the optimal way to
experience both if you do intend to
experience both because I remember I
solidified my concept of this when Game
of Thrones was really taking off and I
got into it after season 3 season 4 was
the first one that I watched as it aired
and you know I had friends who had been
reading the books for years before the
show it come out be like you gotta start
to read the books I was like no don't
wait for the show to finish then maybe
I'll read the books way oh what you're
missing so much and I'm like I know so
I'm gonna watch the show first and what
I mean by that is adaptation by its
nature trims stuff out especially when
you are adapting to a medium that has
more constraints on it rather than fewer
because when you write a book really you
have almost no constraints you can write
anything you have no budgetary
constraints you have no time restraints
you can go on for as long as you want
and describe anything you want you don't
have to worry about what it would cost
to realize so when it gets adapted into
a visual medium whether that be TV or
film stuff has to be trimmed stuff has
to be simplified stuff is missing it has
to be
but I still think you should take that
in first and before anyone goes oh why
wouldn't you want those the you know the
most complete version first I'm like
because if I have that first than I
can't appreciate the other ones if if
the first experience I have with a story
is the complete version of that story
with everything in it that means that
when I go and see the movie there's a
part of my brain that is just gonna be
looking for everything that isn't that
didn't make it everything that's missing
everything that's odd everything that
wasn't how I imagined it whereas if I
watch the movie first and especially if
I like the movie I watch the movie I
enjoy the movie it's a good time it's a
good story it's good characters and then
I get to read the book and go oh my god
there's even more of this thing that I
already like that's terrific
and and reading the book afterwards
doesn't diminish the experience of the
movie because I already have my positive
experience with it certainly the first
time and it's easier to recapture on
subsequent real watches if that first
one wasn't diminished by sitting there
going well they didn't use that line oh
they cut that character but I liked them
oh they change that and maybe if you're
someone who can shut off the analytical
part of your brain better than I can and
that doesn't happen to you maybe it
doesn't make more sense to read the book
first for me just doesn't it it
diminishes one of the experiences now
again I did mention a movie style books
table if you are a complete book snob
and care more about the experience of
reading than you do about the experience
of watching movie then yeah that makes
it an easy call for you I enjoy both i
watch a lot more movies than I read
books but I that again has more to do
with me being slightly lazy and time
management I've had books impact me just
as intensely and deeply as any movie
ever
has so a couple of specific examples
just to sort of give you a sense of
where I'm at one of my favorite books
ever is The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy
now the guide to the galaxy movie is
kind of divisive but I feel that in many
ways it's a pretty good movie what I
hate in it though and when I and I I've
gotten fairly cautious about using the
term hate I try and be restrictive of
when I use that but I hate the character
of Zaphod Beeblebrox in the movie and
it's not because he's a bad character or
he's badly written or even badly
performed despite the fact I don't
really like Sam Rockwell in the film
he's fine good even but the reason I
hate him in that movie is because he is
my favorite character from that book
series and they missed key essential
elements to his character they
simplified him
they made him stupid and in the books
he's not stupid he's lazy he doesn't
want to have to think about stuff if he
can get someone else to figure it out
for him he'll do that but he's not an
idiot and the movie made him an idiot
and I hate it but the only reason I hate
is because I'd already read the book and
I know how much better that version of
the character was watching the second
Harry Potter film and I actually do like
you the Harry Potter films and in fact
the fifth Harry Potter film is one of
the few instances where I liked the
movie notably better than the book even
after having read the book first but in
the second film I was taken out of the
climax by the absence of one little
exchange between Harry and
the sort of projection of Tom Riddle
from the diary there's just oh and I
forget the exact wording now I should
have looked it up but yeah lazy ya
notice look at that I like a lazy
character in a book can't imagine one
but Harry Tots Tom because Tom Rizal you
know you just feed it the greatest was
wizard that ever existed you know
basically talking about his own future
self and Harry mocks him and taunts him
by saying I've seen what you are now
your parasite you you are forced to
leech off another to even continue to
exist basically mocking this idea that
Voldemort became a great wizard and
stent talking about what he was reduced
to and what we saw in Sorcerer's Stone
and I love that I love that moment for
Harry in terms of a moment of strength
and standing his ground I love the way
he cuts to the heart of this particular
projection of Voldemort this young
teenage ambitious Tom Riddle I love that
it's so much and it's not in the movie
and that doesn't break the movie that
doesn't break the scene but it does mean
that I got taken out of it cuz oh there
was something that would be there
wouldn't it made the scene better maybe
a little high little I get more but it
the scene didn't suddenly fail because
that was missing but I enjoyed it less
now is there any disadvantage at least
from where I sit to seeing the movie
before reading book yeah and I'll
acknowledge that which is that if you
see a movie and especially if you like
it
that specific interpretation of
characters again specifically I think
character voices and character
appearances becomes what you think of
when you read the book and that can
potentially taint the book reading
experience on the most basic level kind
of robs you a little bit of your agency
as a reader because normal
you have the power to determine for
yourself how characters sound but more
than that if a character has been
particularly notably reinterpreted for
whatever reason and again for better or
worse from how they are in an original
work it can be jarring when you're
reading the book and going boy the voice
of my head doesn't match the way this
character appears to be talking I'm not
even talking like just dialect or just
just the way that like the good example
for me for that is Jurassic Park which
is a case where I actually think the
movie is notably better than the book
but I saw the movie first and I read the
book and one of the things that threw me
off was the versions of these characters
that I knew didn't match the versions
that were in the book that was true of
Alan Grant that was true of John Hammond
that was really true of Gerardo the
lawyer vastly different characters and
it did make the experience of reading it
a little bit weird because I had the the
versions of movies kind of kept poking
into my head but they didn't fit so
there are potential hazards but I
actually think that that kind of thing
is increasingly less common because we
kind of live in an age where it used to
be books were just cool that's the title
that was a hit here's its premise let's
go and do our own thing at this point
adaptation has gotten more has gotten
slavish more often than not and it does
seem that when adapting a lot of these
works these days most studios and
filmmakers are way too scared about
ticking off the fan base by changing
anything it's actually way more common
than at least it feels like to me it's
way more common these days for movie
adaptations of books to not be great
because they don't cut enough rather
than they change too much but that's a
whole other conversation you know what
makes a good at
tation what you know the changes that
need to happen and maybe I'll and maybe
I'll make that someday and maybe it'll
be more organized than this ramble but
this to me was just me putting in my
thoughts on the question of do you read
the book first do you see the movie
first in my mind if you are interested
in both and you have and you do have the
ability to choose which you've taken
first the movie for me is always going
to be the movie so that I can enjoy the
movie and then read the book and
experience that story again but more as
opposed to reading the book first and
then seen the movie and feeling like I'm
getting the story already no but less
book first movie first your thoughts
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff to do buttons links they
take you places such as my patreon the
support is really appreciated and other
links to check out besides but if you
don't have the time or the inclination
or even if you're like me and you're too
lazy to click on those that's ok too
because at the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]